welcome to this video playing Alex from
Germany and this guy is always playing
Bishop f4 not this time
I was I was playing d6 specifically
against against the London okay so maybe
me we can make this a bit more
interesting
Wow we actually transposed to an open
Sicilian remarkable yeah this is the
open Sicilian with every and I think a 5
mm no against c4 there should be six I
think c4 a5 is the way black is is
playing this at least one one way to go
yeah the position is quite similar to to
indict off of course but with c4 it get
some get some a distinct flavor
this was the idea after all
the ideas after Knight c3 apply III and
I'm in good shape
will this is some preparing this
okay maybe just just just move to c5 or
Bishop d7 simply yeah come on let's just
develop castles rook c8 it should be
quite okay for me
this configuration on the Queen side
means that he cannot easily support the
pawn on c4 and oh wait I have I have a
bishop da to b6 maybe I should take this
chance
hmm now quickly played
check Queen b6 2295
so quite nice
might be three okay if I take night be
three to deform
hmm is there any other possibility not
with not taking em probably not but it's
not not bad I mean okay gig I'm getting
this temple and ninety four is another
temple and then possibly be five
stopping nights deform
okay
hmm
oopsie three maybe he can play Roxy
three mmm
but then I can take and play Knight b3
and Da Ponte sighs three dangerous
that's tricky that's tricky
hmm Roxy three is still an idea what a
but I badly need to do is get the knight
f6 into play it's just not doing
anything at the moment
27 to b6 would be would be a nice thing
yeah yeah yeah I am I take Knight B 3
know it B 3 and the a pawn but he's got
he's got Bishop do you one also and of
course if you take you really improve
his pawn structure maybe I can can can
do that taking on C it is not not an
issue and
look see one I can I can take and I
think I've gained gain to tempo Roxy
three look FC one Roxy three I can take
Roxy three this I didn't see it all
and one day of a3 is a move come on
a3 playing on on this this loose pieces
a beef takes on a3 I take e 2 and B 5
winning the night if he takes D 6 I take
on C 3 cakes and then a night move a day
- I - immediately and there's also yeah
one night takes that takes c3 yes this
is probably the critical move let's
let's see
if I take here taken this is not enough
and takes knight b3 mmm yeah well he's
got he's got a ways to answer that and
this probably wasn't okay wasn't good I
really like the idea
yeah but what now them some mistake
unfortunately and that's always the
special moves what tech night b3 does
the special move it's simply not working
well Bishop d1 does not d2 wha wait wait
wait maybe this is still interesting 92
with the tempo hmm Bishop c4 that's
night
yeah that's not d2 this is this is yeah
I need to do that I need to play it I
have no choice but what now is there
some way if I go b5
come on b5 Bishop takes this Knight v3
this is my idea oh it's giving me giving
me the piece
ages blundered a piece I think okay but
he's still got he's got a couple of
pawns
and if I want to go f6 and I don't know
f6 it's not strictly necessary yeah but
it's a useful move I want to I must I
must get the talking looking into play
check 92 was strong actually check yeah
but this is okay it's not hindmarsh
basically tripped
check check check
check
check check check check check check
check check
yeah just like what I just needed to pre
move all the time it didn't really look
at at the moves anymore
Wow he just blundered a piece I think b5
was a bit of a last bullet it's
interesting Bishop takes this night b3
but yes a winner I guess
yeah Bishop a2 wins me just just
trapping the night basically yeah well
my idea my idea was a 3/8 a3 doesn't
seem to work exactly because of that it
was an interesting creative trial but
not really working and this also means
that Jay 97 was a mistake I need to play
this move him preventing night C for me
I mean it's got Roxy won but I still
need to do it I have no I have no choice
now if I take and he takes with the pawn
this may be this move yeah
probably it's about equal I thought I
really should should have something but
this is some nice defense which can be
informed yeah and rook c3 this is very
important that he can fight for the C
file in this way yeah this is just just
losing I mean I cannot I have no way to
defend it I relied on this tactic but
it's not it's not it's not working
and he played played it perfectly all
right
and here yeah this is just the last
possible chance but instead of winning
he lost this piece for no compensation
yeah what can you do
thanks for watching